it is time for braves baseball what a
night one to finish the braves have
beaten new york three out of four times
head-to-head and tonight braves continue
this four-game series at home against
the men from the big apple tooky
toussaint on the mound and tonight a big
night for him and the braves tries to
solidify the back end of the rotation
and by the way he makes his first start
of the year brandon nimmo will be the
first hitter striding to the plate for
the new york mets so tooky's got his
sign the payoff pitch
is caught on a missed he came back to
get nemo good start one out
oh and two the count to conforto
well what tooky toussaint is doing is
pitching an impressive first inning two
strikeouts michael walker will make his
second start as a met ronald lacuna
junior leads off heath pitches opening
it back
and he gets it on the inside corner got
him looking at a changeup and a cunha is
caught looking for the first down so the
braves get a two out base runner we'll
see if marcelo zuna can turn that into
some damage here
swinging a high fly ball left center
field nimbo on the run still going back
it's gone the braves do strike first in
the first
marcel ozuna continues to pummel the
mets it's two to nothing here's joanna
sespadis
a hook is coming and suspenders had no
chance third strikeout for tucson two up
two down again he has excellent
off-speed pitches
but dansby has been swinging a stick of
dynamite
[Music]
and he's just got his 13th hit he keeps
on rolling merrily along big turnaround
first thought about going to second but
dom smith got to it quickly and it's a
lead-off hit for dansby swanson and now
jeff has a hit
in all nine games this year so here is
johann camargo
and waka gets him with the changeup
that's his third strikeout on the first
down in the home second
two down bottom of the second here's
tyler flowers
that's smoke to right conforto retreat
still going back keeps up can't get it
it's off the wall dance me never stopped
running he's gonna come home and score
and it's three to nothing
first hit of the year for tyler flowers
a double and an rbi and the braves add
on ball carried just enough that
conforto kind of didn't really know
where he was right here and just off his
glove double an rbi for tyler one rbi
double out of flowers brings acuna to
the plate
line drive by acuna into left center
field that's down for a hit flowers will
score acuna headed for second helmet
flying he's gonna slide in with a double
his first rbi of the year and here comes
ronald and the braves have two more it's
four to nothing so here's zombies
and a little pop into shallow center but
no drifting out that's gonna drop in
acuna will score on a blue pit from
ozzie albee's
and he looks in the dugout palms up as
if to say i don't know how it fell but
he'll take it it's five to nothing the
nets with a couple of big swings here
can get back in this game as pete alonso
will bend
there's the grounder camargo to second
for one ozzy the turn double play and
away tooky
works around the two walks preserves the
five-nothing shutout
see how that all shakes out the payoff
line drive again left field a base hit
ozuna two more hits tonight
seven hits against the
mets when you're hot that's what happens
who bats here
and that was tipped and caught toussaint
strikes out cespedes a second time
and that is his fourth strike out of the
game now the double play in order bases
are loaded for new york and wilson ramos
is coming up first the o2 pitch
did he go yes he did ramos down on
strikes big second out for tucson
this one on the ground camargo 360 spin
fires a strike and tukey tucson with
four shot out innings
five strikeouts and only three hits
nicely done young man as luke jackson
will take over after four scoreless
innings from tuki giuseppe the longest
scoreless outing of his young career
and he chased it there's a break alonzo
just swung at ball four
and now new york has the bases loaded
with one out three one coming to canoe
and he drives one to right field but
right out of cuny he makes the catch
here comes nimmo here comes the strong
throw by acuna it's up the line and the
run comes in
mets go into the bullpen for the first
time
and making his debut is franklin
killemay
with two out for ncrt
[Music]
a shot to right field of base hit ender
just reached out and poked that
between alonso and cano
and the braves get the run right back
they cash in to hit batsman it's again a
five run lead the payoff pitch
swing and a miss and kilamay has his
first big league strikeout as he gets
flowers it's the top of the order acuna
swing and a shot left center field
wallop that ball is gone a line drive
home run
for ronald lacuna junior and that got
out of here in a big hurry
finally a big smile from ronald lacuna
junior one ball two strikes
and minter blows it right on by at 97.
boy the braves bullpen is striking
people out
strike three called two strikeout
performance for aj minter it is all
atlanta 7-1
popped up shallow right acuna is there
and the braves have wanted 7-1 your
final score yeah it was a great team win
tonight